[Musica]
[Applauso]
buongiorno mi chiamo tiberio 25 anni
vengo da roma e non mi confonde con
l'imperatore perché mi succede
spessissimo vabbè questa era la battuta
comunque agire agire è l'unico modo che
abbiamo per cambiare il domani per me
ager è l'unico controllo che abbiamo sul
presente per lasciare un segno nel
futuro agire non è riuscire a fare e
rifare a trasformarlo sperare in cercare
spero che mi parli cercherò di parlarle
agire è un istinto è un impulso agire è
un momento ma quell azione può vivere le
terne per questo prima di agire tocca
pensare pensare che le azioni ti rendono
chi sei ma non ti sarai sembra strano ma
è così perché agire e vivere il momento
ricordate agire non è riuscito a fare e
rifare fatta di fare perché agire un
inizio un esperienza agire è vita e non
farlo lo trasforma in un rimorso un
rimpianto ancora peggio l'inverno
l'immagine non era tutto questo era era
un privilegio o era un dovere era
evadere tornare la sera tardi a
ubriacarmi di strano e non pensare
perché perché agire a volte può far male
può far tanta paura ti predispone verso
la possibilità di soffrire perché non
sempre le conseguenze delle nostre
azioni sono quelle che vogliamo quello
che ci aspettiamo per questo agire mette
ansia per questa gira e fa paura ci
rende vulnerabili e di quando parlo che
agirà un privilegio è vero perché a
volte nella vita sei costretta a subire
conseguenze le azioni che neanche ti
appartengono e non puoi agire 6 inermi
pensate avere un sogno innaffiarlo galla
verità e darlo in mano a qualcuno che lo
vive nella bugia pensate essere
semplicemente un bambino e non poter
salvare qualcuno di caro che vi sta
morendo di fronte agli occhi può essere
un ragazzo tornare a casa e sapere che
la persona che mi assicurava un tetto
non lo può più fare vedere che il tuo
futuro è già scritto quando nessuno ti
ha ancora chiesto cosa in realtà volessi
fare e da lì sentirsi nel posto
sbagliato al momento sbagliato
continuamente continuamente vedete che
agire un privilegio ma non per questo
ragazzo per quel bambino per noi a chi
da un privilegio per chi non ha scelta
per chi sta in guerra non 50 anni fa ora
2.000 chilometri d'acqua per chi muore
di fame per chi non ha l'acqua potabile
perché non registra e figlia la prima di
cinque anni perché non sa se morirà
chiedetevi che cosa da insegnarvi o
niente
credetemi che cos'ha di speciale io
nulla chiedetemi se potete fare lo
stesso io vi risponderò di sì perché tu
puoi scegliere tu puoi dire giorno per
giorno passo dopo passo ma cc cass
allora cerca di rendere quel verbo
un'azione ora perché domani è troppo
tardi domani non sia il mondo dove andrà
e se non ci riesce ancora immaginati che
il mondo è in realtà sia un grande
videogioco perché tu puoi pensarlo e in
questo videogioco pazzesco sì non può
scegliere dove lasci però puoi scegliere
dove vivere
zingari e a volte lo scenica usati
accade l'abbiamo detto può scegliere
cosa fare accadere immagina che il tuo
passato in realtà è semplicemente il tuo
punto di partenza con le cose belle e
brutte è il tuo inizio di storia
l'inizio del tuo personaggio che tutti i
limiti gli ostacoli sono le tue
occasioni per fare esperienza per così
superarne di altri più difficile più
complicati immagina che gli sbagli sono
in realtà un modo di farti capire che
quel livello non si supera così che a
volte bisogna fare e rifare fare e
rifare
e non puoi aver paura di sbagliare
perché può sempre fare e rifare
la sofferenza è solo una bandiera che
questo gioco per farti capire che anche
tu se un giocatore
e quindi cosa aspetti per chi sta ancora
nel menu inizia la tua partita
agisci progresso permesso
scusate scusate eh
lo so non sto sul palco perché come vi
ho detto in realtà io non ho niente di
speciale quando mi hanno detto di
parlare qua ho pensato a tutte le
persone di cui mi circonda e ho capito
che alla fine questa sia la mia storia
però è la storia di tante persone
persone che come me come tante persone
che vedo qui di fronte a me hanno scelto
di scegliere hanno scelto di agire
che furono
egli vi ringrazio davvero per questa
piccola possibilità che ci avete dato e
di auguro una buona giornata
[Applauso]